[music]
from European capitals from Washington, a
statement is constantly heard
that the sending of various
weapons systems, including tanks to Ukraine,
in no way means
the involvement of these countries or the Alliance, the
hostilities that are taking place in
Ukraine, we strongly disagree with this,
and in Moscow everything  does both the
alliance and the mentioned capitals
are perceived as
direct involvement direct
involvement We see that it is growing
[music]
in Russia we need scrap metal and that's it Let
them supply and everything will be fine that the
tanks were there the tanks we will have, well, the
pioneers will come collect the batteries pipes
Tanks and that's all  they will take it to be melted down it’s
normal to
melt down on our tanks
measurements all over the world we live in order
to fight And to argue life is one and you
need to
understand why we live in order
to kill to destroy to achieve to
prove we need to treat the world with
love
[music] [
music]
[music  ]